e
104 I'm calling the this meeting into
order it's the uh public higher
education study committee an
organizational meeting and uh we can
start with the
introductions sen Tim Lang and I'm Bruth
W I'm Rick Wayne
B
welcome so the first item we have to do
is to select the
clerk so who wants to take
notes do we all take them your
administrative assistance we don't have
one we don't have one what do you mean
you have assistance for all kinds of
stuff over well there sometimes we do
and sometimes we don't I ask it
specifically and it has not been asked
to do it so we don't have a legislative
a taking
notes I'll do we'll take the notes for
today okay so Senator Lang will take the
notes for today and the review the uh
scope of the committee is an act
establishing a committee to study
payment ofua taxes for University system
properties and certain state government
operations which function as business
open businesses open to the public and
establishing a university system study
committee so this is the study
committee um when do we have to elect
the chair no no the chair is you I'm
okay with that I It rotates every every
two years to the
chair don't have to of
Senate that's fine Perfect all you Ruth
so we have
presentations Katherine prenter
Chancellor are you ready to come up do
you want to do it together with the
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee uh my name is Katherine
prenter I serve as the chancellor of our
state's University
system Madame chair Mark Rubenstein
privileged to serve as Chancellor of the
community college system welcome we you
thank you thank you looking forward to
what you have to tell
us
um as
[Music]
backround well the public highered study
committee you put the mic look closer to
of course is that okay um obviously
public highered study committee has been
around for a long time and um both
systems work collaboratively with the
public highered study committee on
legislative matters um and and take you
from from your committee um as well as
at times provide possible agenda items
at the Comm commit may want to consider
um most
recently Governor sonunu formed a task
force for the two actually were probably
20 plus people on the task force to look
at ways that the two systems of public
higher education in our state could
better
collaborate and the task force issued
its report in March of
24 there was then an act did an
amendment to statute an amendment to RSA
187a um requiring that the the two
systems provide periodic reports to this
committee as well as an annual report on
the status of um implementation of
various recom
recommendations that were in that task
force report so the chancellor and I
provided to Aaron
Jones middle of last week
the actual task force report that was
issued by the task force in March of 24
as well as the annual report that we
issued in November and um apologies for
delayed delivery we provided to Aaron
Friday evening a more recent status
report that's dated February 28th and
and that is um in front of you we're
happy to to talk through that um I don't
know if the chancellor has any
thank you Chancellor preventure I would
like to draw attention from the
committee to the director applebe
Department of Education who chaired the
task force uh created by governor cunu
and would also add that the report
included about 40 recommendations some
short-term some long-term some that were
operational in nature some that are more
student facing and then some that are
much larger policy issues and what we've
been able to uh pursue in the short time
since that report was completed are the
things that are more accessible to the
two institutions to work on
operationally we think that there's
still a lot of opportunity from that
report on some of the recommendations
that are more substantial in terms of
what might be done with alignment of the
state's Economic Development activities
with public higher education
[Music]
as a point of clarification here um my
understanding is as we wrote the
amending language of
1450 that the chancellors of both
systems would present to us a quarterly
report on the status of where we are
with those recommendations so it's just
not as needed but it read addressing
higher education alignment outcomes uh
to the public educ high higher education
study committee beginning with the
calendar quarter ending June 30th
2024 and it goes on and it or prior to
that it said um shall submit joint
quarterly reports so it's my
understanding that you know this we
would also receive the quarterly report
that we you know at the end of the year
or wher we are we coming up on another
quarterly report
yes um thank you
representative I believe
that turn on your mic please sorry I'm
sorry um correct me if I'm wrong I
believe the law states the quarterly
reports are as requested by the
committee yeah
and I believe in
December could be getting this wrong
maybe it was early
January you were the chair at the time
of this committee and we communicated
about we had just done the annual report
and so was another quarterly report
necessary and we said the qu the annual
report would suffice I I'm just not
complaining or anything about the
reports I'm just saying that it's four
quarters per year and or if we request
to skip one we could do that but it it's
up to this committee to decide how to
handle
it is that your understanding yes yeah
we we um the chancellor and I worked on
this status report because we knew this
committee was having its organizational
meeting and wanted to provide you with
an update of the work that we've done
appreciated I just received these things
when I came in this morning so I have
not had a chance to look through
everything else but did the 40 points
that you said that you have recognized
is was that be in the in that report in
this report here okay yes and broken
into short-term recommendations and
long-term
recommendations and in this uh update
you telling about what you have done to
date what you have been able to
accomplish out of those 40 today yes the
um again the annual report that's dat
late October early late
October October 20th provides more
detail but the chancellor and I are
happy to walk through some um recent
updates for the report that's dated
February
28th so can you just walk through the
seven instances you have on this
February 28th report so it's for the
record so people can see it and
understand what we're talking about
while I have this paper not everybody
listening to us
absolutely now I'll start with the first
recommendation and these were not in
order these are just the order in which
we prioritize to pursue them enhance and
expand ccsnh H's Early College dual
enrollment initiatives to give students
a compelling Pathway to postsecondary
education by reducing cost and debt
burden early college is an opportunity
for high school students grades 10 11
and 12 to enroll in college level
courses either in their high schools on
our campuses or online the opportunity
is to challenge themselves academically
and to earn both credit towards
satisfying High School graduation
requirements and also college credit
requirements toward uh completing a
college degree the benefit to students
and Families on a purely Financial basis
is significant the state in the last
bium uh provided $2.5 million for
scholarships to underwrite the cost of
these courses and in Early College these
courses are offered at $150 a course
which for three or four credit course on
our campuses would be somewhere between
645 and
$860 so significant savings to students
and families made more so by the
investment of the
state last year New Hampshire High
School students enrolled in 54,000
credits which if they had done that on
our campuses would have cost at least
$13 million that's largely covered by
the $2.5 million from the state so in
essence a 5 to one return on that
investment most of these students are
just taking one or two courses and over
time you know again if they subsequently
enroll at a college for year institution
where you pay by the semester this may
not amount to much but our objective is
to actually build these into Pathways so
that the sets of courses students take
whether it's 4 or 8 or 12 or 16 over
time actually represent a semester or a
year or even the complete Associate
Degree for students who are ambitious
and motivated so that students and
families can see significant savings
significant avoidance of
debt we've been trying to build build
these with House Bill 1530 in mind which
was a legislative mandate for the
University system community college
system to work better together to ensure
that students had clear Pathways how
coursework at our institution fit into
degree programs in the University system
so that students would have a pathway
that was well defined and contribute to
that both incentive to continue and
affordability for doing that over time
with growth in this program we think
that we can help more students and
families complete degrees that are
meaningful to them aligned with New
Hampshire's Workforce need and because
New Hampshire has always been or long
been one of the leading exporters of
College Bound students students leaving
this state to pursue College in other
states we think that given enough
opportunity to strengthen these Pathways
we can give students reason and
incentive to stay in New Hampshire both
for the 2-year degree that we offer and
the four-year degrees that the
University system offers so we think
there's a lot of benefit to this last
year with the state support enrollment
in Early College grew by
16% 30% on campus about 14% in the high
schools so significant growth
year-over-year this year funding is
continuing same level as last year we've
seen an additional 8% growth this fall
and we expect that we'll see continued
growth into the future with continued
support from the state I should mention
also that about 30% of this enrollment
activity in high schools is happening
with CTE Career Technical Education
Centers so high schools that are closely
aligned in delivering programs that
match many of our skilled technical
programs this the second item on um the
bottom of page two there was was a
recommendation made by the task for task
force relative to simplifying the
admissions processes between the two
systems and again as the chancellor um
mentioned there have been a 100 Pathways
100 transfer Pathways um put into place
between the two systems but we're also U
looking into directed well we are we're
doing a direct admit program between the
community college system and the
university system so if you are
graduating with an associates degree
from the the community college system
you will automatically be admitted if
you meet that um GPA Etc automatically
admitted to the university system and I
believe this month um community college
system will provide information to the
university system so that we can reach
out to those those students and say
congratulations on completing your
degree at the community college system
please know you're automatically
enrolled and that will that's part of
the U directed mitt process we're also
working on it's in this we're also
um working on Direct admit with high
schools that hasn't been rolled out just
yet there are some um statatory issues
relative to sharing data um but the the
two systems are also working on a direct
admit program with the high schools so
if you meet eligibility criteria you'd
get a communication from the community
college system Andor the university
system congratulations on finishing your
high school degree you're automatically
enrolled in in um a public HD
institution here in New Hampshire so a
area I I'd like to stay on this one just
for a second or two and we three months
ago we were talking about the
communication directly to the juniors in
high school hey you graduate and you
have this point average or whatever
you're come on on board you come to Kean
Plymouth or
UNH um and but we also recognize there
was a hangup on acquisition of the
addresses and that of
students have we not yet gone is there
is that not resolved with the doe at
this point in time or the schools
themselves why are we now you know you
know putting this thing off longer and
longer it it's not 100% resolved
representative
lad I I was able I believe with
assistance from director applebe to
connect with a colleague in the
Department of Education to at least
begin to explore this as noted in the
report between our early college
programs and names that can be acquired
through the College Board student
students who take the SAT we have a
significant portion of the secondary
school population that we could reach
out to but it's not a complete outline
it's not a compete census of that
population it's it's more uh students
who have self- selected in in one way or
another so our interest would be able to
more even-handedly and consistently and
systematically reach the additional 20
or 25% who are on the sidelines not
because everybody necessarily needs or
is going to pursue a 4-year degree or
even a 2-year degree but we think that
there's probably a range of
opportunities whether it's skills-based
Workforce training some of our
microelectronics boot camps other kinds
of very targeted programs that provide
Pathways to good opportunities that we
could introduce people to so we are
hoping that there's a more uh systematic
Universal opportunity out there can I
follow up follow up uh thank you um
Chancellor Rubenstein
one of the things we were discussing is
that we know that we have X number of
kids that are graduating from high
school we have an X number of students
in junior high or juniors in in high
school why is it that we can't at least
get some part of this program going by
communicating with the counselors in
these schools or the principls in these
schools and saying hey here the cards
hand them out at least to your students
uh so they are aware that they have this
opportunity to go right on to
postsecondary
education I I I think it's fair to say
that both of our systems we have
colleagues who are in high schools
throughout the state speaking with
counselors speaking with students that
we can
reach where we have a gap as being able
to communicate with families with
parents who may have interest in
understanding what those opportunities
are who may be influential in in helping
to shape the opportunities their
students
investigate I also add representative
excuse me representative glad that of
course the name of it is going to escape
me but there is um an app or a tool that
many if not
most high school juniors and seniors use
um for for college admissions and Keen
Plymouth and UNH are all on that
platform for direct admit for New
Hampshire students so if you meet the
eligibility criteria you click through
in the app and you are directly admitted
and I can absolutely get more
information on that I think that would
be helpful to to understand but that
that was rolled out I think six or nine
months
ago go ahead uh thank you madam chair I
I've had extensive experience with us as
president in Massachusetts um my
question is do the students taking the
courses get a transcript from your
school and students receive an official
transcript from the institution happens
to be a student at conquered High School
the transcript would be issued by nhti
if it happens to be Oyster River would
be issued by Great
Bay follow follow um have you done any
research on how the students are doing
now that you have some experience with
them um I had some experience with the
high school sending the students they
didn't want and I caught a couple doing
that because you
hopefully they literally you can admit
them on the spot because all they have
to do is produce the high school
transfit when they graduate right so
have you done any research on how these
students are doing now yeah we we we've
actually done fairly extensive research
looking at about 35,000 students who
participated in Early College from 2016
through 2022 so that we'd have the
additional two years to see what happens
afterwards we know that about 83% of
these students go on to postsecondary
education we know
that about 6,000 of them enroll in the
community college system about 6,600
enrolled in the University system 11,000
all told enrolled at um in New Hampshire
about 14,000 left the state for
postsecondary opportunities now there's
some overlap in those groups because
students enroll at one place then
transfer to another but we know that
these students have tended to be success
in completing degrees our goal is to
have more of these students succeed in
completing degrees here in New Hampshire
and doing it in less costly ways that
don't put the financial pressure on them
that many college graduates
welcome set line Thank you so mle I'm
GNA drag you into this conversation now
um so is the issue is a statutory
problem that says that you don't have
access to the student data that's
necessary in order to provide the
letters and saying hey you're on target
to graduate you have the right GPA
you're automatically admitted into nhti
or the university college system please
contact us to pursue this is there a
problem with getting that data and needs
a statutory fix or is that something
that they can do by sending a letter for
you so we don't have to deal with them
giving personal data to the to the
university system or the college system
I I I think that would be ideal for
Department of Education do I defer
director applebe I believe in fact there
are some limitations on what the
Department of Education is able to
families thank you uh Steve Alby
Department of Education um my
understanding this is not my area in the
department we actually have a meeting uh
the vice Chancellor and director myself
uh and one of my other uh fellow
directors as well this week next week
it's coming right up to look at this
issue but my understanding is some of
the issues are contract with college
board or whoever the test provider is
that we get this info from that we can't
take that info that we have access to
and give it out I believe that's that's
the issue so we're meeting it's either
this week or next to see what we need to
do to go back to the vendor to modify
the contract so we can then use that
data whether it's us sending something
out or sharing that information with the
systems and this is the app that someone
was just talking about that you're
talking about what what is the kind no
that's a different so that's probably
Naviance is that it the app yeah so a
lot of our our high schools use a use a
post-secondary planning tool um and for
my kids it was Naviance was the name of
the company and colleges put in you know
information into this other
post-secondary opportunity information
goes into this and um students then
access that to try and figure out what
do they want to do next in life so it it
counselors so again maybe this is a
question to Rick and and and and Ruth
but um but it's the whole point of what
we're trying to do is to make sure
instate students stay in state right so
we have to get directly and let them
know early and early on that you have
direct admission already to the
community college system or
how do we what is needed to make that
work again that may not every student is
already thinking about college they may
not be using the application thinking
about their postc where they're going to
go to college right but getting a letter
will spur that convers spur that thought
especially like I'm already admitted I
could just go find out and go right and
so what is the limitation to making that
happen yeah I I think the limitation on
our end is who can we share data with
and is it contractual that's holding us
back is a state statute that's holding
us back who can we share contact
information with which but again I guess
that's the information I want to know
right again if it's a statutory problem
I want to fix it right and get the data
the goal is again to encourage as many
New Hampshire students to stay in New
Hampshire and 10 to Hampshire colleges
right and so if that's the purpose then
let's get the law out of the way if the
law is the problem and solve it so that
we can get these letters out to our
Juniors and seniors and get them know
that UNH is is an option PSU is an
option keen st's and option the
community college system is an option
let them know like you're already
admitted just click the link and fill
out whatever you know where you want
what you want to do um kind of thing so
I guess I want just want to know where
that problem is so I guess that's going
to be my first ask is let's get that
data back to us so we know where the
problem is and in facilitating that I'll
get that answer back to you absolutely
you want to say something yeah yes I do
Madam chair um yes we had this problem
when we were dealing with the College
Board in the past of accessing the
parents information so they could tend
send the SAT scores directly to the
parent rather than having come back to
the school school to the parent that
delayed the whole process that took
statutory change to allow that to
occur Senator Lang is correct it
wouldn't take much of a legislative fix
to fix that portion but I don't think
this is the problem with what we're
talking about I think the problem is
that here we are now in the month of
March and we have students right now
that are starting to
College as Juniors and looking to put
families together as far as family trips
what once we going to go visit what are
we going to see what are you thinking
about doing with your life therea high
school and so I I just can't understand
why we can't get information out
directly to the
schools regarding hey we have this
direct admission program come visit us
or you know look at our campus down in
Kean or Plymouth or UNH uh think about
us as instate we can help you out and
and you know have those counselors or
the schools get at least a a postcard to
the kids right now if in fact we can't
direct mail to the address of the
student and that needs to be worked out
so we can do
that I just want to be here next march
to have a same conversation so that's
all so let's get a fix let's find out
what find out what's necessary um again
if it's statutory we'll work through
that um but I think again to Rick's
Point kids should have you know students
should have a letter in the mailbox
right now saying hey you've already been
admitted to un and you've already been
aditt in HTI assuming you keep your your
course going your your academic progress
going so reach out let's go let's move
this right and and let them know um
right up the bat I still want to be back
switch go ahead just a quick comment um
maybe the public schools aren't as
enthusiastic about losing students uh as
we think they might be but um the other
thing I wanted to mention when we had
this I was President North Shore of
community college for 13 years um we
picked up students under this program
who are having trouble adapting to the
public school environment including
students on IEPs because I had a massive
student and IEPs hit a ball when they
graduate from high
school and so they would show up in this
crowd and and and flourish because they
were in a different environment in a
class with adults not other teenagers
that might make fun of them and and that
was a big advantage of the program as
well um I I can't answer uh chairman
last's question
about that but um I'm wondering if
there's something else going on why
wouldn't they want their students to go
in this program you were a
superintendent one didn't you I can't
imagine any kind of a high school
principal or administrator in a district
saying uh we don't want to do this I
think it's just basically have those
cards been sent out have are they aware
that there this program is available
they should know it as Juniors right now
I have a junior and outside the state in
another school and we're already
thinking about you know we got the Fisk
book out you know the one with all the
different colleges Best Buy this and
that we're looking at that and saying
well where are we going to go this this
spring or this summer and start looking
at these schools and I and uh for the
students we we talked one of the other
areas which we addressed within this
task force report was affordability and
accessibility well the schools here in
our state are accessible and they are if
we if we can let them know that there's
some affordability issues like gr
Granite guarantee uh which might be also
informative information for these
Juniors that yeah you can stay right
here and go down to Keane and have a
wonderful
three I just want to say we're on it
we'll we we'll Circle back the one thing
I I will point out though is um in my
opinion we don't just want to focus on
the College Board because those are
students who are taking the sat there
are lots of other students who and and
we talk a little bit about this in the
report um right now because there is
this disconnect we can get the data
about the college board but we're going
to be a little inconsistent until we can
have a process in place to make sure we
can get to all students regardless of
whether or not take the SAT so this is
the gap and I think director applebe was
touching upon it with the contractual
relationship with the College Board
student can sign up to take the SAT and
some students do but the state also has
contracted with the College Board to do
assessment and so every virtually every
11th grader and it's that gap between
the students who independently sign up
where we can reach out to the College
Board in essence pay for information
about those students to reach them and
that group of students who have not
independently signed up for the SAT
whose only information would be through
the college board but again we're
present in every High School in the
state we can reach the students who will
come to the table and sit down with us
but to be able to reach every student
every family and as I said before not
everybody needs or is interested in
going to college but the kind of college
level learning that a student can have
through our programs gives them a found
Foundation if they want to go into the
military some foundational training that
may be helpful for a specialty that they
want to pursue just has a range of
benefits that encourage students who may
not be confident that they have the
potential to be successful as
representative Burton said some students
find themselves thriving in a different
set of circumstances we want to give
options to to number three I I think
both cancer prevention and I have both
referenced in the first two uh House
Bill 1530 we ought to note the key
sponsor and that was representative lad
that became the foundation for a
significant amount of work that
continues building well articulated
Pathways between uh the Community
College systems programs and the
University Systems programs giving
students road maps now across a hundred
different programs that map from
virtually any of our our seven colleges
to any of the three us and H
institutions that that ensure that
students have a way of of mapping their
future not squandering time and
opportunity and
cost and on in that VIN um academic
advisers have been trained um we have a
we call it an Outreach Enrollment Center
it's half a dozen people at the
University system works on a whole
variety of projects but um phone calls
texts emails to stay connected to
students and and so that group um is
being leveraged to stay in contact with
these students who may have questions
Point them in the right direction um
make folks aware of of what those
opportunities
are there there was one question we had
on that would the application of
software test transfer something
something
system E I don't know transfer
equivalency system okay um so have we
made any progress with that in terms of
these 100 plus different Pathways now
that we've really aligned up we have
made some progress um UNH is standing up
tests I think and I'm correct me if I
get these wrong because there's another
one called transferology that we're
still evaluating but test is the
transfer equivalency and and we are
making progress on that and ccsnh began
to Pilot tests at National community
College we're in the process of of uh
filling a position for somebody who will
have responsibility for doing that
systemwide is that a delay thank you so
again to tie this back to our last
conversation right we were talking about
the matriculation of students rolling in
whether it's a high school student
rolling in the community college system
or the university system or the
community college system rolling into
the four-year University system um again
have we we made alignment
and and our students like hey you just
you just graduated a two-year RN degree
if you want to go on to you to the
university system here's all the
fouryear you uh RN degrees you could get
in the schools that provideed that kind
of mapping the show that here here's
what I got in Community College by my
associates was in this and that'll all
transfer to the college system here's
the programs and schools that offer
those programs we have that kind of
mapping so that's it's Unique to the
student again I if I'm a nursing student
I don't really want anything about
engineering
right and so uh so telling me that you
know University system has an
engineering program is not going to be
useful to me but you tell me they've got
more Healthcare programs that my
community college degree will transfer
into are we doing any of that we're
we're we're part way there if you go to
the UNH website for transfer what you
will find is a map for any program that
you're interested in will take you to
the institution's degree program show
you how your CC SNH associate degree
aligns with the course requirements to
complete the bachelor's degrees it shows
up as a PDF which is a little bit less
Dynamic than you would ideally want so
the next phase of this is to have
something that's more interactive where
a student can do almost um what if
scenarios what if I take these courses
what choices will I have as opposed to
having to sort of map from from a
particular degree at a particular
institution the long-term goal is that a
student would be able to put together a
series of scenarios to know that this
set of courses could take me this way or
could take me this way keep in mind
general education course is going to be
widely fluid um but if you're are
interested in a science technology
engineering math uh field you know which
math courses are going to be relevant
which ones are going to become electives
that may or may not be useful so to give
students more tools more interactive
tools to map is the next phase of this
that we've got to get to thank you
welcome have
question as we discussed this you just
becomes more interesting to me that we
we have the concurrent dual enrollment
program where the kid can take so many
courses at in the 10th 11th and 12th
grade when a a student ends up having
taken well you know you take let's say
six credit hours during one year so
multiply that by three there's so 18
credits when you're notifying them that
hey you have the option to come have
direct enrollment and admission to this
school but you also are carrying 18
credits you might be almost a second
year you know semester freshman um
that's also encouraging to somebody to
stay in a state and the final the
question I have how many of these kids
are using these courses they get through
running start to come to New Hampshire
or they just carrying that load
somewhere else to go to school like you
Mass um as I shared earlier we know that
over an extended period of time we've
had 6,000 of the 35,000 come to ccsnh
and about 6600 enroll at usnh in any
given year about 10% of the recent high
school graduates come directly to CCS
andh over the next four years we
actually see almost one in five of those
students whether they started somewhere
else or they simply took longer before
they
matriculated but but we know that
students are making use and that all
predates having these solid Pathways the
assumption is that and and it needs to
be tested but the assumption is that if
we do a better job of building Pathways
and not just the courses but building
experience for students the opportunity
to come and visit our campuses to meet
with our faculty to see the facilities
that we have the university system has
that over the course of those two or
three years where they're taking these
early college courses we can cultivate
relationships that encourage the
likelihood that they will follow through
on the
opportunity may I follow follow love
this
conversation so the the students which
are taking advantage of the concurrent
dual enrollment program I was probably
surmised that many of them are doing it
because M or dad pushing or that there's
a a support for higher education within
that family we need to really be
targeting as you've mentioned before
Mark Tumi that these kids which maybe
didn't have any intention of going to
school or maybe not coming out of a
family like that uh are you seeing a
higher proportion of an improving
proportion of students which are now
taking advantage that which are going to
higher ed which before hadn't it it's
going to take time to fully realize what
the potential is we assume that the
majority of students who had been doing
this in the past were the students who
would either take an AP or an honors
course or in this case an early college
course they already had intended to go
to college their families already have a
plan as this begins to grow and
particularly the place where it's grown
most notably over the last few years as
I mentioned earli about 30% of the
students participating are enrolled in
CTE centers three years ago that was
less than 15% we're starting to see
growth in participation among students
who are in programs that better align
with some of our technical programs who
might not have fully appreciated that
there's a post-sec
postsecondary degree aligned with their
career interest that will actually
strengthen their position in New
Hampshire's Workforce so we are starting
to see students who probably in the past
would not have been looking at this as
school I have a question on the uh
possibility of a three-year bachelor
degree sure I see that you're not
requiring 96 uh credits how how many
credits for a fouryear degree 120 how
many 120 120 so there significantly less
what is eliminated from a three from a
three-year program from a four-year
program to manage a three-year program
this so this um will be considered a
professional bachelor's degree I think
that's the the terminology um some
electives uh may be eliminated actually
Plymouth um will have all five of these
stood up this fall and um oh maybe it's
applied applied bachelor's degree not
professional and so some electives will
be um not part of the degree um Senator
I don't know exactly for each of those
five programs which courses will not be
part of the the degree um but again I
will surmise it's it's a and I can get
that for you if it would be helpful and
this is these were just approved by our
regional crediting board Nei in the
fall it's
um there are other institutions around
the country that have um adopted the
same type of Applied bachelor's degree
you know it's really part of meeting
students where they are and as chancell
Rubenstein talked about you know the
opportunities for high school student to
almost complete an associates degree
some may Embrace that some may not not
it's it's Again part of meeting our
students where they are so Plymouth is
the only one so far the only one so far
is Plymouth that's right they they um
and actually when I touched face with
them late last week they've accept we
don't the deposits aren't due yet so we
have some deposits in but I probably
wouldn't pay my deposit in
advance um they've accepted 149
applicants into those five programs so
far and 95 of those are um the business
administration applied bachelor's degree
I'm just thinking right now there's a
big need for teachers for example would
that fit in eventually into a three-year
program um I I am going to surmise we
would need to work with the Department
of Education right because there's
certifications and and so I don't know
all of the requirements necessary to be
a certified teacher in the
state I I can add a little bit to that
seeing I've gone through that those
there's certain internship program
student teaching that's required um it's
a very comprehensive process and and so
at this point in time I would suggest
that we we don't look we look at these
trade areas like the cyber security like
the police training program the robotics
the outdoor recreation those are the
type of programs which I know president
Burks looked into in with his community
and with his staff it's important
important to know that these programs
are not just coming out of
administration they've been approved by
their staff and professors and assistant
professors and adjuncts that are
teaching these courses they're all on
board and that makes the program
successful well there must have been a
survey which programs have the
highest uh
need yes and they work with their their
provos Mr bich up there who has done
survey work with his staff with the
community and I think that's how they
arrived at where they're going to go
with these five courses and I think it's
a fantastic idea could it also hits the
idea of
affordability and and gets the students
out into the real world to learn that a
dollar is a dollar and perhaps the
student who representative last
suggested had accumulated 18 credits in
high school that might most of them may
be able to transfer to the three your
college unless they're taken a lot of
electives agreed and again it would be
part of the pathway right these these
Stu these courses in the early college
will map to these programs and these
institutions again I'm encouraged by
this right I understand you got to walk
you know you got to crawl before you
walk right and I think we're still in
the crawling stage we got our first five
degree programs at one University I'm
sure Keen as it looks at its
opportunities we'll be looking at
opportunities UNH same thing and each
have their own little Specialties and
might have different three-year programs
so I this is great work and a great
start to it I might go think about take
my threeyear police studies program up
at PSU so I'll go have a chat with that
H your back and angry Madam chair mam
chair please thank you um thank you m
chair thank you there is a huge audience
out there of partially completed college
students and you can get the data from
the loan there's a loan file and if they
get a letter saying you you've earned 20
credits so far did you know if you come
to the Community College or a four-year
School in New Hampshire you can complete
that degree and get your degree and get
the ticket that that you
need some states are doing that
know yes I'm going I'm going to back up
to number four because I'm I'm really
excited about
it um the university system office is
relocating to the New Hampshire
Technical Institute campus um we'll be
occupying the bill building right behind
Chancellor Rubenstein on the campus I
I'm confident that we'll we already
spend quite a bit of quality time
together but I'm sure this will improve
collaboration um we are scheduled to
move it constructions underway right now
um to get the building ready and uh we
will be in there by July so it will um
save the university system about
$250,000 a year in rent and provide a
revenue stream to the community college
system at the same time so in my opinion
it's a win-win all around to to occupy a
a building on the Community College on
the nhti campus that was underutilized
so
I I think it's also worth noting that's
a clear physical symbol but the
conversations Chancellor preventure and
I and our respective colleagues have
been happing about other opportunities
for administrative uh collaboration are
are continuing to grow and I think we'll
both recognize savings from those
efforts but also more seamless uh
interaction between the two systems that
will benefit our students over time and
um just following up on the Chancellor's
comments there there have been a number
of
administrative um collaborations so the
university system has an e-procurement
tool it application that that it uses um
we were able to secure I think three
seats in that tool for the community
college system pre of charge so now the
community college system we can leverage
scale um give ccsnh access to our
contracts vice versa um the next wave of
that might be some um better
collaboration into the contracts
management tool that's part of it so
that's one example we're having
conversations around can we share risk
management um resources can we share
facilities and capital anything again
both
systems um we have some headwinds and so
we need to be looking for efficiency at
every turn and so it's
um this this work has just provided the
platform for the two systems to work
closely
together so the two systems are
sufficiently similar so that the staff
won't be
confused can you actually share the same
Personnel well so so um in some areas
certainly not all in some areas so let's
talk about when I say risk management
well both systems have to have insurance
on their
buildings um so maybe there's a resource
that we don't need of two full-time
people maybe I don't know we can work
out something that one Sy we could one
system could pay the other system for
for part of
that employees time if you will um same
thing with capital planning and
Facilities is there is there some
something there that we can leverage so
those are things we're exploring
sometimes it it's a dead end but it's
question can I have six another question
uh for both of you um several years back
we were
informed that there was a program that
was offered down UNH and Durham that
they were going to move up to Plymouth
State I believe it was the athletic
training
program and I think that's that's a good
idea to be looking at our curriculum and
our offerings that way uh seeing that
that you know rather than having
something split apart bring it together
in terms of what we've been just talking
about from your side in terms of
managing contracts and business aspects
and all that are we now starting to
engage in when a school like for example
Plymouth came out and said we're going
to go in these five Cur our small
three-year
courses if if say Kean or UNH is saying
we're going to go this direction is
there any kind of prior to going that
direction there's a communication with
the central office of both right here
the at the Chancellor's level saying
wait a minute we're starting to
duplicate a program we have over here
and that's going to you know split
little Revenue that we have have going
the directions maybe we better putting
it all in one pot um yes representative
lad absolutely that is part of the
process there there are Provost meet
monthly um and before any new programs
are rolled
out there is conversation this just
happened within the last couple months
there's conversation
around I'm I want to start this program
what's at your school what's at your
school now the the the the real bang for
the buck will come when
when our online infrastructure
systemwide
is humming at 100% because what we'd
like what we need to be able to do is
have a student um take a maybe they're
they're living and studying at
un and that course isn't offered there
because they've eliminated the athletic
training program but they have it at
Plymouth
so that we're working on that right now
that has we
can't University system what understands
100% we can't do everything we're doing
now it it doesn't work so how do we best
leverage and integrate academic
programming not just administrative work
but academic programming as well and our
provos are working on that as we
speak can we have you know this is one
of our long-term recommendations we have
in the governor's task force report and
it talks about exploring offering
Community College courses and university
courses at different
locations uh
and is there and it sort of aligns with
what we just finished talking about of
trying to you know offer at his campus
the course which is actually made
streamed over here at that course but
it's it's I think that's a real cost
saving to the student um do you have any
kind of information on on how we're
moving in that direction as far as the
number of courses we're actually trying
to do this now in I don't have details
on the number of courses representative
lad
I will guess in the next few months I
will we will have details on on courses
as I said the provot are working through
this question right now now
MH we know that's where we have to
go I hope so you know that's that's
where one of the reasons why we hired
the president down at UNH she is very
involved in what she did out in
Washington in that state college system
of bringing them under one accreditation
which I think you're aiming at Mark a
little bit with the community college
system with single
accreditation that's a perfect lead in
Chancellor preventure just said a
perfect lead into to the sixth item
we began last year to to evaluate the
opportunity for single accreditation
regional accreditation is a single
Statewide Community
College it's a
substantial and complicated decision we
didn't want to ask our board to rush
into that so we've spent the better part
of the last year working with the
national Center for higher education
Management Systems asking them to do an
objective analysis data informed and to
develop a set of options for us we're
expecting to receive a report this week
we expect that our board will receive it
this week and we'll share it widely with
the legislature with other stakeholders
over the next few months to evaluate
what makes sense one option is single
accreditation and to some degree it has
the potential to uh address some of the
issues that you just raised the
efficiency the UN removing some of the
intra system competition that may exist
for enrollment in certain programs uh
allowing students to more seamlessly
navigate and take courses where it makes
sense to them particularly for our
population which rather than often
living on campus on a residential uh for
a residential institution our students
are working adults by and large they may
be working in nsha but they may live in
conquer or they may live in in Littleton
but they may have a job that takes them
to
uh to to lonia so the ability for
students to participate in curriculum
where it makes sense but not to lose
ground because those pieces fit together
would be one potential benefit of single
accreditation when we receive the report
I anticipate though that we're going to
see a range of options some of which may
be addressed not by changing
accreditation but by changing
institutional and system policies that
allow students to get those same
benefits without as much structural
upheaval right now as you might know the
national landscape and higher education
is is complicated um and regional
accreditation is an area of perhaps some
uncertainty so at least one part of the
consideration is how much energy to put
into uh addressing regional
accreditation when that landscape is is
fluid and and that effort may not be as
sensible but we are committed to
looking at options that allow us to
better serve students and to find
efficiencies are certainly part of it
but as I've said in other settings I I
think postsecondary education is growth
industry that there's going to be more
demand for people to continue education
over the 40 or 50 years of a working
life and we've got to figure out how to
reallocate our resource and our energy
to support that growth not simply think
about the contraction of the traditional
age demographic so we would expect that
within the next week or so we'll have a
report that will go first to our board
and then be circulated across our system
and beyond and we expect that'll be the
basis for discussions and deliberations
over the next couple of months to see if
we can map out what the next step is for
the community college
system those of you who served in the
legisl for any length of time know that
that you don't make a single decisive
decision and that's it for the future
you make the right decision for the
foreseeable future knowing that you will
at some point perhaps revisit it to
either sustain that direction or or
modify as as circumstances and and data
dictate thank
questions go ahead just one observation
we through all of this we have to keep
our eye on
quality what's happening at different
levels and so forth um I happen to be in
the legislation when the when the system
was
formed and John Tucker was speaker he
was a Plymouth State
graduate proud and he was worried about
the image of the university and Flagship
and two tugboats so he had the vision
for the system and it was first out at
at the U Le traffic circle and and the
president of unh was the chancellor of
the system well three schools and um it
was an interesting
experience but this is a natural now
step forward to to systematize it small
s and and to link things together but
I've been through this before and you
got to keep your eye on quality what's
happening what
distinguishes what happens at a college
of University from a secondary school
my so where are we in the agenda here
how much have you covered to have them
number seven left like yeah there was
just there was just one other item we
talked about six we tal yes um the
chancellor I just talked about six um
that the seventh item there's a
recommendation in the task force report
that talks about engaging with business
communities across the state um to build
Partnerships with business industry
public high
Ed even k12 and we stand ready to
participate in that um however it's I I
um frankly it can't fall on public high
industry business and industry needs to
engage engage so the chancellor and I
will um reach out
to Taylor Caswell the Department of
Economic Affairs um we think there's
there are Regional the acronym is Cedars
development organizations across the
state um I believe that would be the
place to start to engage bring HED to
the table so that so that there's a
more communication back and forth
between the needs of employers and and
highed so we just want that item hadn't
been included in previous reports our
status reports and we both thought it
important to include that we want to
start that work we haven't started that
work but really in in my opinion
Bea needs to help drive that I think for
students to have an opportunity for an
internship it's always very very
exciting for them because they can
actually see what the real life is and
what what they can do and also maybe
prevent them from continuing if they
realize that this is not what they want
to do right 100% and and um across the
university system the the inter we are
plugged in to employers through
internship programs um I think a lot of
this is also about looking forward and
thinking about
what does the what the does business and
industry and our employers uh what does
curriculum need to look like in the
future how do we plan for that together
all of those things with
internships um
mentorships certificate programs it
doesn't even have to be degree programs
right what does what does business and
industry need and how how do we deliver
on that and that to really have a
partnership well into the future do you
expect the problems lining up enough uh
internships or experiences in the actual
industry well um much of the time what
we find with internships is students out
ofate students who participate in
internship are twice as likely to stay
and work here in New
Hampshire the tough part of internships
sometimes is that they're not paid yeah
and in this climate when a student can
go work at Target part time for a good
wage or not get paid when they need
that's that's an issue as well the other
thing here in New Hampshire so many of
our businesses are small businesses and
so an internship program takes some
infrastructure right so um there's
there's support needed there that they
might not have to to have an effective
internship program we're working with
small businesses on that but it's it's
another challenge for our small smaller
businesses in the
state so there be a
uh fund that bigger businesses could
contribute to they will give a stien to
the people who go to smaller businesses
they can't get the salary and I can see
that as an
opportunity not that the small business
can actually pay the intern anything but
they can get a grant money so they can
afford to do
suppose have to after more
money if if I might if I might offer
credit commissioner Caswell for having
some foresight for a number of years
he's talked about the need for three
three-sided uh uh structure to this that
includes higher education State policy
makers and business and industry at the
same table to problem solve these kinds
of issues Chancellor preter and I both
meet regularly with commissioner Caswell
as part of his Council of partner
agencies I do think
that likewise uh Chancellor prevention I
both are connected to the business and
industry Association so I think we have
the right players we just need to find
the table where we can sit down and
problem solve I don't know if this is
something that
uh we would want to unilaterally suggest
is the right strategy to ask the
legislature to put together a fund for
this I think think that conversation
with Partners from business and industry
and with u Bea might be a a good
starting point for framing what might
work s delay so again the way I read
number seven wasn't about internships it
was more about when I own my business I
read a great book it was not the big
that eat the little it was the fast that
eat the slow right meaning that you got
to be nimble you got to be able to move
or you're going to get overtaken and so
the way I read this was the ability for
the universi to be nimble to work with
our New Hampshire employers to be able
to see what are the needs of New
Hampshire employers right now and
developing things I can know that it may
be a five-year cycle and then you're
moving on to something else because the
industry's changed or 10e cycle in the
industry's changed so you know I I think
it's important to work with um The
Business Leaders you know Bia is a great
one but they're also got a huge umbrella
about things like the hospitality
industry and tourism industry in New
Hampshire which is so critical to what
we need and what those Employers in
those areas need um I know I share ways
and means we do gaming and gaming
industry is desperate for getting
trained dealers and trained servers in
their in their charal Gaming facilities
so again I read this as being that I
think it's important that the uh
University system of the community
college system engage with those and I'm
going to call them more granula than Bia
or Bea is that the hospitality
Association or the you know the tourism
Association the you know there's a
manufacturers Association there's
industries that if you bring them in
they'll tell you this is what we need
and they know right for the workforce
what's needed and what's lacking in the
people that are coming into the
workforce now that need to be
strengthened that may provide some
opportunities for you guys so I guess I
would encourage you to be a little more
granular and go to those industry
specific associations and say we want to
work with you guys to help you with your
Workforce what can we do and what can we
provide and do a lot more granular work
no no disagreement with you on that
point I think we're both connected to
New Hampshire life Sciences both
connected to Army both connected in more
granular ways but at some level just
looking for where are we missing the
opportunities and to some degree hoping
that Bia and Bea may help us find those
places where where we're missing only
comment I'll make is the long the higher
up the chain you get the more delayed
the information is right so if you're
talking to the hospitality industry they
know what's going on in their industry
last week right versus B Bia not got
that information for another six months
by the time it's rolled up in the Su
report right and so the idea of again
engaging with the more granular you know
especially the uh the industries in the
Hampshire that are key to our economic
success right and engaging with those
the hospitality industry tourism
industry the those kind of things Marine
industry right the Lakes W Lake wi Lake
W Squam Lake Squam Lake right they all
have what kind of programs might work
and help those Industries get workers
that can come work there and keep the
Hampshire's
economic absolutely agree 100% Senator
Lang the this is a a good example though
of the difference between the community
college system and the university system
so if an industry or an employer needs
something tomorrow the community college
system is is more able to deliver on
that our um almost all of our colleges
within the University of New Hampshire
and at Kenan Plymouth have advisory
boards from from people in business
saying okay let's think about what do
you need for
curriculum four years from now what kind
of what kind of skills are you going to
need to help develop the curriculum so
there are two we we're our curriculum's
thinking a little further ahead while
the community college system is I
noticed Mark jot down oh excuse me
Chancellor Rubenstein jot
down you must have mentioned something
about the gaming in industry and their
their that is a per in my where I sit
that's a perfect example of something
that the community college system is
here to do um anyway
so I think our if I could speak for the
chancellor we can't this in my opinion
this can't be one and done we need to
set up a process why how do we get more
granular and those Cedars those Regional
Economic
Development
um the regions might be a way for us to
be intentional so it continues in
perpetuity and it's not oneandone we we
H public H Ed needs to be part of the
landscape
so this a quick note um when I face this
problem on the NorthShore and I was
chairman of the NorthShore chamber I
realized the chambers do show and tell
that the government people don't have
time so I formed the NorthShore Alliance
for economic development on my campus
and I had politicians I had Bankers
anyone with a self-interest
lawyers me and actually do e development
work based around my office and with you
two in the same place you'd be an ideal
place to to do something like form your
own organization they'll come because
they want they want to get together and
do real what what needs well anyway I'll
just leave it at
that if I may Madam chair I'll add one
more point that we're facing a math
problem in this
country this year I think 4.2 million
people will reach age 65 we'll have
about 4 million high school graduates
and that will be true for the next
several years the number of people it's
not that the workforce begins at 18 and
ends at 65 for most of us but the
reality is that we're no longer
replacing as rapidly as we once did and
we've got to figure out how to fit Get
Talent find Talent everywhere develop
Talent everywhere and fit Talent where
it's needed throughout the state as one
of the older states in the nation we
face that problem more acutely than
other parts of the country and we've got
problem any more questions from the
members on
set anything else you want to tell us
just thank you for your time I think the
chancellor and I feel pretty passionate
about this work and so we're delighted
to to um take a little bit of your time
this afternoon well you have your work
cut out for you thank you m chair yep um
I thank you very much for coming in
today and and going through the the
points which are in the corly report uh
I'm looking at the task force as a total
that report back from March um there are
short-term initiatives and there are
some long-term
recommendations some of long-term
recommendations are going to take a
while to get there however I think it's
important that this study committee
address some of those or at least have
some discussion regarding I'm I'm
looking at the first one I could go
through them all but the first one and
the last one are excellent but this one
says analyze the fiscal assets and
program utilization across both
systems um you're you're doing it with
your I'll call them the central offices
you're coming together over to nhti but
but where are we in terms of all these
assets between the seven community
colleges and the University Systems
three main branches I'm not talking
Manchester now or or conquer so where
are we are there any Capital thing costs
or fiscal assets which you know maybe we
could better utilize in terms of maybe
inviting industry in or or or putting on
the market you and because all we're
going to do is you know have deferred
maintenance deferred maintenance up the
wing wang and that's going to drive
everything up too
so we we are so um the university system
is very much focused on that right now
we are not working with the community
college system on evaluating footprint
um we have sold buildings we've
demolished buildings we're getting out
of leas space we're now looking system
each of the campuses looked at space
utilization now we're looking systemwide
what how else can we leverage um those
assets we know the footprint needs to
shrink as enrollment declines we have
not yet started conversations with the
community college system about I I we're
we need to get our house in order I
guess is where where I'm sitting right
now far be it for me to correct
Chancellor preventure but in fact they
have worked with us and That's the basis
for relocating the system office to
faram Hall on the nhti campus we have
sold some smaller properties we are in
the process of figuring out better uses
or having conversations about some of
our facilities as you know our programs
are very local we're in every region of
the state because that's where we serve
and in that regard as opposed to a
system level conversation each campus
leadership team presid is taking a look
at the physical plant that they have to
figure out what makes sense for the
future um nhti has three residence Halls
one of those is currently being leased
to uh another entity that can make
better use of it generates revenue for
nhti we are looking across our system at
where we might make better use I I will
offer also as we I think said in other
situations there may be state agencies
when I hear commissioner Arling house
talk about his 12 bucket buildings there
may be state agencies that are not
well-housed that that we could partner
with uh our Littleton facility at White
Mountains community colleges houses new
H an office of New Hampshire employment
security as an example several of our
campuses now have made space available
for Head Start programs we're currently
leasing uh space in our Berlin Camp uh
Campus of White Mountains to um uh Boys
and Girls Club of central New Hampshire
to provide child care in that setting so
we are looking at all of our spaces
against Community needs against better
use of those facilities than we might
have for them may have just follow up
that that's good conversation I I would
like to you know if we could in the near
future maybe at another meeting um be
looking at these physical assets which
we have and how they're being utiliz
whether it be down in Keen where the
community college is on the same campus
or you know what we're doing in in
Manchester with the Manchester plant
there with the medical research and all
that if this is an area where I'd like
to know where we're going with these
Capital costs and what areas are we
looking at building and do we need to be
building or should we be renovating or
should we just be selling off or you if
if Madam chair if we could have
something come back to us in that that
is one of the recommendations in fact
the top longterm recommendation we have
here in this report uh I'd like to start
looking down at some of these
recommendations here and seeing I think
this is where we need to be going I'm
also looking at the last one right here
which talks about we're in the buying in
budget right now and establish as well
let's have a a two-year look at let's
have a a four-year look at a six-year
plan uh where are we going in terms
of prioritizing needs which are going to
be out six years from now um that's all
I know the trustees look at this stuff
uh however where we as a responsibility
here in this study committee need to be
I think also looking at that in terms of
how are we going to communicate to our
legislative bodies which take care of
some the finances here for example markx
already mentioned about the concurrent
dual enrollment program and we see that
as a wonderful way to get kids into this
into this system learning trades and and
getting this experience I can do it at
the high at the college level and
staying in this state uh so but you know
I and but the budget request comes in at
two and a half at $3 million or three
and a half or three and a quarter and
we're knocking it down to two and a and
a half is that really short-sightedness
or is that just based upon what's
available and that's all we got uh but I
I'd like to be making decisions on the
priority of of the system in a long
range plan rather on on singular
programs and maybe when somebody comes
in the program oh I love that program
that's what we're going to fund is that
the top priority from you for uh uh our
looking at the buying and Bud budget
this is an important area Madam clerk
there's a lot of good recommendations in
here I think we need to start looking at
these long-term recommendations as
well you can easily ask for a long-term
plan you know well yeah they're here in
this
when are you going to do what you know
which what are the priorities where do
you want to start and well start here
they're
stting yeah but you know on those fiscal
assets I think that's one way we can
start because I know you've got CTE
involved in some of that You' got
community college system you know on
Keen State um we've got real housing
problems up in uh
Plymouth uh for our m program and Beyond
uh even for kids so I'd like to have and
we're deferring
maintenance so I I'd like to have more
information on our fiscal assets
okay you got that right newly
noted anything
else just one more remark you got to
raise the salary offered to the in your
ad for the president of uh Nashville
Community College it it's the average
salary of a dean and I know this is i'
I've had some calls from friends in the
community college network saying that I
can't apply for that because it's not
higher than what I'm doing now I know
this is not your fault this is New
Hampshire you know on the cheap but just
just a comment and I think it would do
the legislature well if if you were able
to offer a market salary for that
position got to remember that our our
system gets fewer dollars from the the
state than any other system in the
okay did you have anything did you want
it any wishes for the next time so thank
you madam chair so I'd be interested in
maybe talking to high school principal
on how it relates to the students the
the 10th 12 11th and 12th graders we
were talking about is what they see is
what is the do they even know about the
fact that we have this automatic
enrollment process and what are they
doing to get out there their students
and and just see again from the from the
principal's position the High School
principal's position what are they see
is limitations of helping them get the
students into the higher education and
get we talk
about five right identify stakeholders
so I'd love to see a high school
principal come in and chat with us okay
um I know the K principal is asking to
come and chat with him so I'm sure I can
maybe talk him into coming down um and
maybe a winam one yeah maybe a WI princi
I can talk to okay and see if they'd be
interested in coming down and
specifically I want to focus on the area
of of post secondary of of of like
really College in the college system and
how they're interacting and how they're
getting information
to get a different perspective from a
different level of people did you have a
your
wish pardon me did you have a wish
something that you would like to know by
the next time the stakeholder that you
like to hear
from I know I I think the E development
plan for how the community colleges fit
one do you have enough pH workor I I I
do Madam chair but if I may make one
comment
please
I representative Burton did not make his
statement in the form of a question but
I would still like to respond we have
been fortunate with then the resources
we have to attract very talented
leadership to our colleges and although
I'm sure we lose in a search some
candidates for whom that level of
compensation will be a barrier I don't
think it precludes us finding very
talented people and I would look at the
panel sitting in front of me who are not
drawn to serve in the legislature by the
salary they're drawn to service and for
leadership at community colleges that's
often true doesn't mean they shouldn't
be equitably and and appropriately
compensated but we have the benefit of
people who care about the mission and
who will come to deliver quality for
that Madam chair I just say that one of
the problems you have is Lucille's shoes
are really hard to fill uh she was one
of the most highly respected presidents
in the
country any other suggestions for uh
future stakeholders or stakeholders that
we would like to hear from when the next
quarterly report doe next report is do
January quarterly oh that that report
28th not going by the year like January
to this February so the next one is
to June
right is well it does May suffice is the
next report quar in June or July May
would be good we want to come in June
okay may is fine I have no problem with
together okay it
is reply M chair we're looking at some a
Monday sometime in May we'll just look
at look at the calendar and see what it
looks like going forward understanding
the Senate is going to be neck deep in
our budget so anybody have a calendar we
could set a tentative date
calendar May 19th is that May 19th so
how about tentatively May 19 is the
afternoon a good time for you or would
you prefer the
BF okay I know May 19th and you after CT
advisory Council meetings on Mondays but
I don't know if there's one scheduled
that well let's put it down and then
we'll see what
happens yeah May 19th in the afternoon 1
P.M
okay so May 19th in the
afternoon tentatively and then we'll
double check and see what
other committees have been scheduled for
that same time thank
you um anything
else Mr applebe do you have anything you
want to say or
well I don't hear anything else so
unless somebody has anything else to say
then we can adjourn the
meeting all VES in favor I
I the meeting is
coming happy